Oh what's going on you two check it out
so I know I said that I'll be putting
out a video every Friday but this one's
a special one because I have a couple of
announcements before we go ahead and get
into that let me tell you guys a quick
story apparently for those of you who
don't know I actually started up a
Twitter per your request
now I had no idea that when you Twitter
somebody back it wasn't called twatting
it's called tweeting apparently and I
just um so when I had a conversation
with a specific person she didn't take
it too well
oh yeah I don't really appreciate this
important thanks for the [ __ ] excuse me
do you think that's funny what I say
person that I've said that to it wasn't
a joke I honestly thought it was called
warning I won't say it anymore
what okay I'm done anyways this past
week I said to drop a visit to my former
high school foreign high it was for a
key Club of men which is a community
service club that I used to be in it was
a good experience so I decided to kind
of go ahead and put up some clips for
you guys to check that out pretty good
before I wasn't really that much else
book I was always a goofball Mikey look
kind of gave me a that and thank know
the comic in up on stage my very first
performance actually started up as
musician before
and I to announcements t-shirt designs I
currently have about four out I'm gonna
show you guys three see if you guys like
them and leave it in the comments which
ones you like which ones you like the
most
I don't know which ones I'm gonna make
maybe I'll make all of them who knows
but I also don't know what sizes and how
many I should order depending on how
many people want to get it so go ahead
and drop a line drop a comment let me
know what your size is if it's like xxx
on my bed I don't know if I could a [ __ ]
announcement number two I have a show
coming up in San Francisco State
University it's a Korean culture show
that's gonna be on April 22nd so it's
coming up real soon so if you guys want
to see what I do for a living
stand-up comedy go peep out that show
I'm gonna have some of the information
at the end of the video and oh and also
on the 23rd if you missed the 22nd one
you guys can go ahead and check me out
at a show that I'm doing in Berkeley so
I'll be doing stand-up comedy as well
but yeah come on through say what's up
is this show see what I do if you don't
come out I hate you guys I'm kidding
don't go subscribe come on
ha gotcha